good morning John let's do a quick
overview of our last day of tour just so
I can remember it
here it is we've arrived at a place to
stop to be food what is it now
the usual I can go to the healthy
station yeah just have a single piece of
cheese or what why is that banana milk
is that a real thing are you saying I
look for John Ross daughter oh that's
nice Rach can you be in a video just I'm
just asking your permission to put your
face in the video oh really
damn it what do you think it smells like
that all candy oh yeah Panera nominators
Oh oh god that's something that's going
awful that sounds like fake bananas it
was in the healthy section
[Music]
and that we stop for video making
for John video pet area that dog have a
crown on its King dog his name is crown
he's gonna poop John found a real weird
tree here three like doesn't have a
trunk it's like a tree made out of dirt
ooh nice change on careful though don't
hurt yourself thank you
I mean Pizza John photo shoot time look
at this chain oh yeah your chains real
dirty actually don't let this on my body
anymore how can we actually go into the
farm it's unlocked I mean it's super
cool so soft through window
wow the child San Francisco
[Music]
[Applause]
darkus that's where I'm hard to heart
there's no care together no compass and
no anchor doing dumb [ __ ] with this
anger pumped kisses undone this is just
fine business that young mistress you
swapped tongues with this doll that
these bones the old Hackney angler you
brought the beasts all of these
harmonies of insolvency it spiritual
deficit in poverty dropped
you ready ready let's do it
I'll show she's gonna miss the bus so
much thanks for showing up real early
Thanks oh my god this is a big place hey
there it is in the basement these are
the books John's gonna sign
[Applause]
[Music]
how you feelin good a little nervous I'm
just going through her question oh we
got questions and we got don't uh
doesn't happen every night thank you to
whoever gave us Donuts I would now like
to bring to the stage for the very first
time human brains are remarkably
flexible I've been lucky enough to have
had a bunch of moments of tremendous
positive shift in my life going to
college to summer camp moving to a new
place going on and coming back from tour
it's amazing how fast I find my brain
shifts to accept that this new life is
my life now and then when I go back to
my old life that life is my life now
that transition is overwhelming yeah
definitely but it also it's an
opportunity to examine my work and what
I want to be doing and I'm very glad to
have shared this intense experience with
you John and with so many other people
and do have made people happy and to
just think out loud about what it means
to be a person but I am also very very
very happy to be back home John I'll see
you on Tuesday